when you breach a neural network one of
the choices you get to make is what
activation functions use independent
layers as well as at the output unit of
your neural network so far we've just
been using the sigmoid activation
function but sometimes other choices can
work much better let's take a look at
some of the options in the forward
propagation steps for the neural network
we have these two steps where we use the
sigmoid function here so that sigmoid is
called an activation function and G is
the familiar sigmoid function N equals 1
over 1 plus e to the negative Z so in
the more general case we can have a
different function G of Z visually right
here where G could be a nonlinear
function that may not be the sigmoid
function so for example the sigmoid
function goes between 0 & 1 an
activation function that almost always
works better than the sigmoid function
is the 10h function or the hyperbolic
tangent function so this is Z this is a
this is a equals 10 H of Z and this goes
between plus 1 and minus 1 the formula
for the 10h function is e to the Z minus
e to the negative Z over there some and
it's actually mathematically a shifted
version of the sigmoid function so as a
you know sigmoid function just like that
but shift it so that it now crosses a
zero zero point and rescale so it goes
to G minus one and plus one and it turns
out that for hidden units if you let the
function G of Z be equal to 10 into Z
almost always works better than the
sigmoid function because with values
between plus 1 and minus 1 the mean of
the activations that come out of your
head and they're closer to having a zero
mean and so just as sometimes when you
train a learning algorithm
you might Center the data and have your
data has zero mean using a technique
instead of a sigmoid function kind of
has the effect of centering your data so
that the mean of the data is close to
the zero rather than maybe a 0.5 and
this actually makes learning for the
next layer a little bit easier we'll say
more about this in the second course
when we talk about optimization
algorithms as well but one takeaway is
that I pretty much never use the sigmoid
activation function anymore
the 10h function is almost always
strictly superior the one exception is
for the output layer because if Y is
either 0 or 1 then it makes sense for Y
hat to be a number that you want to
output that's between 0 and 1 rather
than between minus 1 and 1 so the one
exception where I would use the sigmoid
activation function is when you are
using binary classification in which
case you values the sigmoid activation
function for the output layer so G of Z
2 here is equal to Sigma of Z 2 and so
what you see in this example is where
you might have a 10h activation function
for the hidden layer and sigmoid for the
output layer so the activation functions
can be different for different layers
and sometimes to denote that the
activation functions are different for
different layers we might use these
square brackets superscripts as law to
indicate that G of square bracket 1 may
be different than G Oh square bracket to
Grandma gain square bracket 1
superscript refers to this layer and
superscript square bracket 2 refers to
the Alpha layer
now one of the downsides of both the
sigmoid function and the 10-ish function
is that it Z is either very large or
very small then the gradient or the
derivative or the slope of this function
becomes very small so Z is very large or
Z is very small the slope of the
function you know ends up being close to
zero and so this can slow down gradient
descent so one other choice that is very
popular in machine learning is what's
called the rectified linear unit so the
rayleigh function looks like this and a
formula is a equals max of 0 comma Z so
the derivative is 1 so long as Z is
positive and derivative or the slope is
0 when Z is negative if you're
implementing this technically the
derivative when Z is exactly 0 is not
well-defined
but when you implement is in the
computer the often you get exactly is
equal to 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 0 it is
very small so you don't need to worry
about it in practice you could pretend a
derivative when Z is equal to 0 you can
pretend is either 1 or 0 MN and you can
work just fine so the fact that is not
differentiable the fact that so here are
some rules of thumb for choosing
activation functions if your output is 0
one value if your I'm using binary
classification then the sigmoid
activation function is a very natural
for is for the upper layer and then for
all other units on value or the
rectified linear unit is increasingly
the default choice of activation
function so if you're not sure what to
use um for your head in there I would
just use the relu activation function
that's what you see most people using
these days although sometimes people
also use the tannish activation function
once this advantage of the value is that
the derivative is equal to 0 when we
negative in practice this works just
fine but there is another version of the
value called the VG value will give you
the formula on the next slide but
instead of it being zero when Z is
negative it just takes a slight slope
like so so this is called the Whiskey
value this usually works better than the
value activation function although it's
just not used as much in practice either
one should be fine although it you had
to pick one I usually just used in
random and the advantage of both the
value and the least value is that for a
lot of the space of Z the derivative of
the activation function the slope of the
activation function is very different
from zero and so in practice using the
regular activation function your new
network will often learn much faster
than you're using the 10 age or the
sigmoid activation function and the main
reason is that on this less of this
effect of the slope of the function
going to zero which slows down learning
and I know that for half of the range of
Z the slope of value is zero but in
practice enough of your hidden units
will have Z greater than zero so
learning can still be quite fast for
most training examples so let's just
quickly recap there are pros and cons of
different activation functions here's
the sigmoid activation function I would
say never use this except for the output
layer if you are doing binary
classification when we almost never use
this and the reason I almost never use
this is because the 10 H is pretty much
strictly superior so the 10 inch
activation function is this and then the
default the most commonly used
activation function is the Randy which
is this so you're not sure what else you
use use this one and maybe you know feel
free also to try to leak your value
where um might be 0.01 G comma Z right
so a is the max of
0.01 times Z and Z so that gives you
this some dent in the function you might
say you know why is that constant 0.01
well you can also make that another
parameter of the learning algorithm and
some people say that works even better
but I hardly see people do that so but
if you feel like trying it in your
application you know please feel free to
do so and and you can just see how it
works and how long works and stick with
it if it gives you a good result so I
hope that gives you a sense of some of
the choices of activation functions you
can use in your neural network one of
the themes we'll see in deep learning is
that you often have a lot of different
choices in how you build your neural
network ranging from number of hidden
units to the chosen activation function
to how you neutralize the waves which
we'll see later a lot of choices like
that and it turns out that is sometimes
difficult to get good guidelines for
exactly what will work best for your
problem so throw these three courses out
keep on giving you a sense of what I see
in the industry in terms of what's more
or less popular but for your application
with your applications idiosyncrasies
it's actually very difficult to know in
advance exactly what will work best so a
common piece of variance would be if
you're not sure which one of these
activation functions work press you know
try them all and then evaluate on like a
hotel validation set or like a
development set which we'll talk about
later and see which one works better and
then go of that and I think that by
testing these different choices for your
application you'd be better at future
proofing your neural network
architecture on against the same
procedure problem as well evolutions of
the algorithms rather than you know if I
were to tell you always use a random
activation and don't use anything else
that that just may or may not apply for
whatever problem you end up working on
you know either
either in the near future on the distant
future all right so that was a choice of
activation functions you see the most
popular activation functions there's one
other question that sometimes is asked
which is why do you even need to use an
activation function at all why not just
do away with that so let's talk about
that
in the neck
video and what you see why new network
do need some sort of nonlinear
activation function